I strongly believe learning has no age
anybody who stops learning stays old and
anybody who keeps learning stays the
younger I want to break all the barriers
and remain in the arena attack world as
it is commonly sheltered don't limit
your challenges challenge your limits
hey I'm Vishnu I am studying in eighth
grade at Oakridge International School
visakhapatnam India
upscale myself with postgraduate program
in artificial intelligence question
collaboration of Simply run and Purdue
University and I have also done a
postgraduate program of cyber security
oxidant collaboration of Simply learned
with MIT currently I am still in school
but I can efficiently juggle between
school music astrology skills in my
routine in fact my routine here is far
more challenging than my routine in
school party because I learn more here
than I learned in school my father
spends time teaching me various subjects
like maths physics chemistry and French
he also helps me in subjects like
trigonometry algebra and probability
initially I wanted to be a doctor but
after coming across so many basic
technological advancements I now want to
be a leading software engineer I took up
courses in artificial intelligence and
cyber security to prepare for the near
future recently I am also certified in
many programming languages such as Java
JavaScript python HTML CSS react
moreover I know the French language very
well and I am certified A2 by Alliance
Francaise I also converted my father in
France sometimes okay
are we
um
the amazing faculty provided by our
University as well as MIT arranged by
simplyon had made by learning experience
very insightful the tests and projects
at the end of each module have really
helped me Instagram my Concepts in
artificial intelligence and cyber
security my aim is to pursue a masters
at top university in the U.S so I am
also certified in grade 5 piano grade
six of keyboard and grade 8 of rock and
pop drums from Trinity College London if
you are not willing to learn nobody can
help you but if you are determined to
learn nobody can stop you I believe that
best view comes only after the hardest
climb